Speaker 1: I invite you to join the discussion
on the David Pakman Show subreddit, you can find
it at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit that's
already DIY tea. We now have about 35000 of our
viewers and listeners participating in discussions
there. A few notable posts I spotted this morning.
One was, Hey, is anyone else receiving Mehmet Oz
text scams? And they actually posted a screenshot
of a text scam they received. That said,
this Dr. Oz report will change your life.
Yeah, I have to tell you, I don't. I get stuff
like this. Also, I get a lot of it via WhatsApp,
interestingly enough. But the I we have no
evidence that this is actually associated in
any way with Dr. Oz, nor his campaign. A lot of
these things are just kind of like preying on the
notoriety and name recognition of people like Dr.
Oz and I think, you know, report it, block it,
whatever but it. It's not clear to me that
Dr. Oz is actually sending out text messages,
trying to scam people and sell them bogus medical
reports. He does his bogus medical reporting on
his own show, which, by the way, is it even going
on now that he's running for Senate? I really
couldn't tell you, but there's all sorts of tax
scams. I actually got a recent one. This is let me
see if I can pull this up. This is an interesting
one. There's a guy called There's this guy in the
crypto world called Mike Novogratz. He's, I guess
he's a gold trader or something. Anyway, I got a
text scam about that one where they wanted me to
give someone money to mirror the trades of Mike
Novogratz. You know, I just reported and block
it right away. I just pulled it up in my trash.
That doesn't mean that these things are actually
associated with the people. I'm sure that has
nothing to do with Mike Novogratz, so be on the
lookout for all sorts of different scams. But
there's many things we can slam Dr. Oz for. I am
not aware right now that he is actually doing this
text scamming. Another post reminded our Reddit
users of a seminal event in David Pakman show
history. This post says Remember that time David
turned out to be a gay teen with AIDS. I hope I'm
not the only one who remembers. Now, this is not
a fun. AIDS and teen gay bullying. None of it is
funny. But what was funny and the viewer
has it slightly wrong. About a decade ago,
I appeared in a film about something really sad,
which is gay teens who are bullied so relentlessly
that they take their own lives. And it's
horrible. That's a real thing, and that happens.
That didn't happen to me, and I was still featured
in a documentary with an in memoriam thing
where I was sort of like, eulogized in a way as a
gay teen who was bullied and took my own life. And
I wasn't a teen at the time. The picture they used
was of me at like age 27. I guess I was youthful
at the time. I was not a teen. I was not gay. I
was not bullied. And I, at the time was very much
alive. So that is an incredible moment. And David
Pakman show history, not a not not a funny topic,
but sort of kind of curious that I was included
in that. And yeah. OK, thanks for reminding us.
And then lastly, Michael Cohen mentions
David in his latest podcast. Yeah, this
is cool. Many people may or may not know this.
Trump's former lawyer, Michael Cohen, who now
is playing a really prominent role in a number of
different investigations into Trump and has a very
successful podcast and on and on. He he watches
the David Pakman show. He's in our audience.
It's great and we'll we'll exchange messages
sometime. I was on his show, he was on my show.
He sometimes will make some of the jokes we make
on this show that make it clear he pays attention.
He was interviewing Kurt Eichenwald
and he brought me up. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: If Trump is so, Trump is president,
but Biden is president and the guy is like, Yes,
Speaker 4: I think that David Pakman,
who was actually doing a video like that,
I saw I saw something like that who was with
a husband and a wife, and he just started
fumbling around. I could not figure out.
None of it makes any sense. And how can
it make sense? You can, you know, it's OK anyway.
Speaker 1: So that was my cameo by by
namedrop on Michael Cohen's podcast. It's a great
podcast, may I call, but I do recommend people
check it out. Join the discussion at
David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.